All right.
We should never
forget the brave men and women
who helped bring World War Two t
And now a new series
from the producers
of Band of Brothers
and the Pacific is attempting
to do just that.
Masters of the Air is on Apple T
It chronicles
the courage and sacrifices of US
bomber groups
who fought behind enemy lines.
Take a look.
All that we do
day in, day out.
The sun will guide and.
We fight the masters.
The things these people are capa
They got to come.
Trust me,
Lord.
Guard and guide the men who fly
through the great spaces of the
We tested the men.
On what side?
That side be with them.
Traversing the air in darkening
Joining us right
now, series creator John Orloff.
John, great to see you.
I mean, you're well known for yo
on HBO's Band of Brothers
and the Pacific,
and now here we are
with the Masters of the Air.
I mean,
how does this feel now
after working
all of this time, what,
it was about ten years or so wor
and then now seeing it to fruiti
It's it's been an amazing experi
Yes, indeed.
It's been ten years
trying to make this and making i
It's just been
the most complicated,
ambitious thing we've ever tried
So we're all very excited it's d
and that the world now gets to s
Yeah, and complicated, too,
because of
just capturing
the personal stories, right?
Because, I mean, look,
my dad's a Tuskegee Airmen. My l
He was a gunner, right?
I didn't know that. Right.
But you know, now interviewing y
Well, no. I mean, I.
I don't have all the stories
because my dad is
of that
generation of men and the Tuskeg
Airmen who did not share the sto
So I am a consumer
of what you've got there,
because I would love to hear,
you know, fill in all the blanks
because it was a very difficult
I mean, of course,
they are proud warriors,
but it was a very difficult time
And so that generation,
you know, of of men and women
kind of suppressed
that they didn't
want to impose,
you know,
those hardships,
that experience on everybody els
I mean, we could go on and on ab
But so I'm wondering,
how were you able
to capture those stories in orde
bring this depiction?
Well, this
one was a little
more difficult
than being under the Pacific
because the guys were no longer
with us as they were when we mad
And he interestingly,
they would talk to people
that weren't their family.
So when we made bands,
they would talk to us
and often their family members
would come to the interviews
so that they could hear the stor
for the very first time.
This time, though,
we didn't have that luxury,
and so it required
an awful lot of research
from me
and a whole bunch of other peopl
to sort of
figure out all the true stories
that really happened to these me
and to capture that
and put it on to the screen.
That was our challenge.
Yeah.
And it's challenge
because it's it's huge.
I mean, there were so many peopl
so many individual stories.
So you kind of truncated it down
let's talk about two men
specifically and their journeys,
Major John Egan and Major Gail C
Is it 11?
Correct. Yeah.
Okay. Okay.
And how did you you know,
how did you select those two?
How did it come down to getting
Back and say,
I can say that one was a decisio
by Steven Spielberg
and Tom Hanks before I came on t
I think it was Steven
who read Masters of the Air,
the book first.
As soon as he read this book,
he was like,
We should make a series
about these two guys,
Buck and Bucky, as their nicknam
And they're just an amazing two
who volunteered
in 1940, almost two years
before the war began,
and they became best friends in
and they remained best friends
till the day they died.
And it's it's really at the core
of this story is their friendshi
And it's an amazing
and amazing friendship.
Oh, my gosh.
Amazing journeys and adventures.
And you're going in
unexpected places in the show.
But all of it true.
Yeah, I know.
They're going to be a lot of tea
in watching it. So what are you
You know, people
who are going to be
watching Masters of the Air,
What are you hoping
they're going to learn?
They're going to, you know,
really gain from them?
Yeah, Well, well, well, You know
don't really know what happened
up there in the air
because the technology to make a
has never existed to show the sc
and the extreme
nature of combat at 25,000 feet
and 40 below zero
in unpressurized cabins.
And so I'm we're really excited
for people to see the scale of t
and the unbelievable sacrifice
that this generation of men made
to free Europe
and keep
the rest of us free and build a
absent of Nazi ism.
All right.
Hey, thank you, Tom Brokaw.
That's why
they are the greatest generation
Exactly.
I mean,
there is nothing more fitting no
There was not a more fitting tit
for all of them.
All right.
John Orloff, thank you so much.
What a pleasure.
My pleasure.
Thank you so much. Wow.
I'm kind of amazed at
you being
the daughter of a Tuskegee air m
We'll talk another time.
Okay.
He was a pretty awesome man.
Very awesome man. Thank you so m
All right.